we already know that when Donald Trump
was elected he promised to cut ties with
his businesses by putting it putting
them into a blind trust we found out he
didn't even know what a blind trust was
but he went back on that promise he
instead turned some of the businesses
over to his children he still is getting
financial reports from the kids and the
big thing is that Donald Trump didn't
divest from his companies like other
presidents have done and that would be
really the way to avoid conflicts of
interest so it doesn't actually matter
how much Trump knows about what's going
on at his businesses he still knows that
these hotels he has are in the family he
knows about the other businesses and
remember this total charade of a press
conference a week before the
inauguration which was meant to sort of
us wage our fears about possible
conflicts of interest remember this
thing president elect Trump wants there
to be no doubts in the minds of the
American public that he is completely
isolating himself from his business
interests these papers are all just a
piece of the many many companies that
are being put into trust to be run by my
two sons and I hope at the end of eight
years I'll come back and I'll say oh you
did a good job otherwise if they do a
bad job I'll say you're fired goodbye
everybody yeah I'm sure after eight
years that he'll just be shocked to find
out all the stuff that happened while he
was president or four years he's not
gonna have any idea right it's hard to
believe that Donald Trump's sons Don and
Eric aren't updating him on the state of
the businesses so that's what we knew
already okay here's the news about this
we now have learned that Donald Trump
can also draw money from his business
whenever he wants without telling anyone
the General Services Administration
released some documents last week one of
which we're putting on the screen for
you these are changes made to a trust
document which include a clause that
says the trustees shall distribute net
income or principal to Donald J Trump at
his request or as the trustees otherwise
being appropriate this can include
profits from the businesses themselves
and being able to take profits from the
company also would be an indicator to
trump
about how the company's finances are
looking because if there are profits to
be taken out that means that the
businesses are making money and for
anyone who thinks oh the documents have
been like this for a very long time this
is something that the Trump's went back
in and added Trump's kids they added
this language after the inauguration
after Donald Trump did his song and
dance about disconnecting himself from
his businesses a frederick canceled
who's a family estate and trust attorney
outside of DC he reviewed the documents
for Pope ProPublica he said quote it's
incredibly broad language the Trump
Organization is a private company Trump
doesn't have to disclose when profits go
right into his pocket they just will go
right into his pocket and Donald Trump
is not even required to report or
disclose the profits in federal
financial disclosures the only way to
see the drawers that Trump is taking
from his businesses would be you know
where I'm going Pat release the tax
returns which yeah we know about that
already and this latest story brings up
a lot of ethics concerns and conflicts
of interest angles but we also know that
he's benefiting from the taxpayer
because when he travels to his own
resorts or when his family uses his
private airplane the Secret Service has
to reimburse those cots oh and they go
back to trump it's a total kleptocracy
and steven rosen saw Rosenthal who is a
senior fellow at the Urban Brookings Tax
Policy Center said quote for tax
purposes it's as if the trust doesn't
exist at all it's an entity on paper
nothing more Eric trump recently told
Forbes that he plans to regularly update
Donald Trump about losses and
profitability etc it is all a sham we
have a kleptocracy we have a president
knowingly able to make decisions
impacting the country and in some cases
the world to enrich himself and his
family Pat how is this helping the
average voter who supports Trump they
believe that because Donald Trump made
so much money in his businesses that he
would be able to use those skills and
help the American public yeah we know
that he's not only not helping the
American public but he's also enriching
himself to the state and just wait until
we
reveal the details of trumps tax reform
plan which might be the next failed
disaster of the trump administration on
today's bonus show cat chaos is hitting
producer pat it is scandal number four
or five at this point that pat is
bracing against also our habits that you
have just to be safe considered
superstitions I got a few emails from
the audience about that I will update
you about the YouTube monetization
crisis hint it's a disaster I don't
usually swear on the show Pat but I've
been tempted to swear many times when
discussing this issue we are trying to
replace the ninety-eight percent
reduction in YouTube revenue that we are
experiencing overnight through no fault
of our own due to what is known as a
YouTube advertiser boycott in the short
term I'm asking you to go to
patreon.com/scishow throw in a couple
bucks a month we're trying to get to 500
patrons at patreon.com slash david
pakman show that's PA treo n.com slash
david pakman show and of course you can
become a member at david pakman.com
slash membership and you can also use
our amazon link david pakman.com slash
amazon any time you shop at amazon more
including the crazy cat controversy on
the bonus show today